I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her I did not
[Music]
so in 2015 when the force awakens' came
out I took it upon myself to review
every single Star Wars movie leading up
to that film I talked about the holiday
special even the animated Clone Wars
film I was very happy to have all those
reviews done because I liked the idea of
being a completionist when it comes to
reviews I like covering a wide variety
of topics I like having a nice archive
of reviews for people to come and watch
and with the last Jedi coming out I
thought to myself wow I'm so happy I've
reviewed all the Star Wars movies and
then something began to eat away at the
back of my mind something was nagging at
me and I realized what it was the
made-for-television a walk movies oh my
god it wasn't until the past few years
that I even knew these things existed I
have never seen them before
and I tracked down a DVD of both of them
and I watched the very first one caravan
of courage made for television in the
year 1984 takes place between the Empire
Strikes Back and Return of the Jedi
let's talk about it so despite the Ewoks
negative reception and Return of the
Jedi someone somewhere must have liked
them this entire film is narrated by
burl ives who you might recognize from
things like Rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer he has a very famous voice and
Lucasfilm must have learned their lesson
from the notoriously awful holiday
special which featured rookies talking
to each other with no subtitles and
barely any human beings to interact with
so you had no idea what was actually
happening because this time around this
narrator quite often explains the plot
for us in an Ewok village on the moon of
Endor
each tries to summon two of his sons who
went into the woods
and have not returned my fears they may
be lost so this movie's a giant boar
it's one of the most uneventful Star
Wars films I've ever seen in my life and
it'd be easy for me to be like well this
is just a make kids kids of the 80s who
wanted to sit down with their families
around the holidays and watch this on
television and sure if you were a kid
and this came out you might have some
nostalgia for it I've never seen this
before so I'm looking at this through
fresh adult eyes and it is one of the
most dull and boring films I've seen in
a while for instance one of my favorite
parts of this movie are these two Ewoks
kicking each other's asses because it's
just two Ewoks fighting
that's the entertainment value they were
talking about here but for the most part
this entire film is about this family
that crashed landed here on Endor a
young girl her brother and their parents
who have been separated and abducted by
this giant called the Gore axe and the
girl and the boy go on a journey with
the Ewoks to try to find his hidden
mountain fortress and a whole bunch of
magical things happen along the way that
are never explained despite our
narration that helps miss out often one
tree in the primeval forest contains a
special fluid which only he walks nope
they have used it for generations to
cure the ills and unfortunately these
two kids don't have much experience
acting for the young girl it was her
first film for the boy he somehow even
worse just don't worry his star hotel
till we get back I will protect you I
will be long dead on the bright side I
am a fan of matte paintings and this
film has some really good ones
so eventually giant Pumbaa attacks the
two kids and they get stuck in a tree
and they decide to just kind of go to
sleep and it just fades out and then
when they wake up the Ewoks are fighting
Pumbaa yeah I think so but we better
spend the night just get some rest just
get some rest and this right here is
where it becomes very apparent that it
was made for television because this
film relies on those commercial breaks
those fades to black and then the desire
to get up and do something else while a
commercial is going on for its pacing to
work they're relying on audience members
to get up and go to the bathroom or get
some popcorn out of the microwave or
something so they have that disconnect
so that when the movie fades back in
after whatever commercials they were
watching it feels like the passage of
time is correct but when you sit down
and just watch this movie without the
commercial breaks the the timing of
everything and the pacing is thrown off
and that's the sign of a really bad
made-for-tv movie when they rely on
those commercial breaks to make the
pacing work when it feels like it's
overseen by a network like it's some
corporate product one of the best ever
is Stephen King storm of the century
it's actually a miniseries it's not
quite a made-for-tv movie but it just
feels like a film when you watch it from
beginning to end it doesn't need that
break to make the pacing flow now this
is one of the most difficult scenes to
explain because it makes absolutely no
sense but it's also the first scene that
lets you know that a lot of things are
going to happen in this film that don't
make sense the kids visit a mystical a
walk who spins a giant top that shows
them where their parents are they're
being held captive by a giant Gore axe
and then they perform some kind of
ceremony where everyone is given a
specific item the boy gets a rock the
girl gets a candle and then these stupid
feather things are given to the Hawks I
don't want a rock
yeah so with her special items in tow
the caravan of courage sets out for the
gore axe hideaway and along the way a
tree falls down because an Ewok chops it
down with an axe and the boys angry
reaction is extremely delayed so this a
walk decides to join them on their
journey to try to save their parents but
before doing so they engage in an axe
throwing contest
[Music]
[Laughter]
now right around here I paused it to see
how much I had left because it was just
getting too much for me and I realized I
was only halfway through I'm showing you
the highlights okay honestly I struggled
watching this the majority of this movie
is just these kids walking around it
with a walks and then wicket going
[Music]
and it crashed
yeah that's it don't you have to start
Cruiser
[Music]
so another mystical II walk puts
something in the kid's hand and it turns
into a lizard then the little girl picks
it up and it turns into a mouse and
because of whatever just happened this
wizard like a walk agrees to go with
them on their journey
despite the narrator explaining
everything else he doesn't explain that
then the kid is looking at some water
and he touches it for some reason and he
gets zapped underneath even though his
reflection remains
there's an entire pointless action scene
where this horse runs away with the
little girl trapped inside an Ewok has
to slow the horse down and calm him it's
like they're scrambling to find
something to do besides walk around
because that's all this movie is just
some kids walking to a mountain it's
like Lord of the Rings except not good
eventually Tinkerbell shows up and then
a whole bunch of other Tinker Bell's and
then the little girl is like oh I have a
candle I'm going to put the candle down
and all the Tinker Bell's form a little
Tinkerbell tornado and go inside the
candle and then come out as one
Tinkerbell Hey look what I got what
actually is happening in this movie
there's a narrator explaining things
left and right but they don't explain
anything that doesn't make sense so
eventually they make it to the mountain
where the gore axe lives and the kids
special Rock opens up and he has some
kind of key that lets them inside
there's a giant fucking spider and one
of the Ewoks uses his magical walking
stick to hypnotize the spider then
wicket fucking shanks a spider like
straight up stabs a spider multiple
times it's one of the better parts of
the film so the kid catapults himself up
to his parents to free them and he does
the giant sees them and wreaks havoc on
the very obvious walls of the film set
and my favorite part of the film
happens
[Music]
yes my favorite part of the film is when
an Ewok is crushed by a bunch of falling
rocks and unfortunately this poor child
has to act sad because the Ewok dies and
apparently the one a walks magical green
stone on his walking stick can not only
hypnotize giant spiders
it can make rocks fall from the ceiling
of this mountain and the kid has to
throw the axe which is I guess like a
big arc for his Ewok friend who taught
him how to throw an axe and then he died
so that's like a the big moment of the
movie so now that the families reunited
everybody goes back home and dances it's
not - yup nope though unfortunately it's
- something else I don't know some song
that they dance - caravan of courage is
nowhere near as bad as the holiday
special it's not that embarrassing
it's just painfully uneventful and
nothing happens really just kids walking
around with a walks and some weird
magical shit happens the best this movie
has to offer is sort of a nostalgic feel
for 1980s television but I've never seen
it before so I couldn't even connect
with that oh shit there's another one
it's called battle for Endor stay tuned
for that review coming soon guys thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]